I read this interesting commentary a
little while ago on a statement by Christ
in the New Testament,
and the statement generally interpreted
is that the meek shall inherit the
earth,
but I was looking up the multiple
translations of the word Meek,
and meek is actually
derived from a Greek word,
of course,
because the Bible,
at least some of the original
forms of the Bible were in Greek.
Um,
and that word didn't exactly mean meek.
It meant something like
those who have weapons and
the ability to use them,
but cert,
but determined to keep the
machines will inherit the world.
And that means that people
who are capable of force,
let's say,
but decided not to use it,
are in the proper moral position.